we spent a long time building a content
provider but we are only using it just
enough for us to test that we got the
content provider working when we query
the database here's how these classes
are used our UI first builds URI using
the weather contract the UI then uses
this UI to call a method in the content
resolver which ultimately forged the
request to our weather provider our
weather provider uses weatherdb helper
to get an instance of SQLite database
creating or updating the tables of our
database is necessary we then pass the
SQL query to the SQLite database class
we send our query off to our SQLite
database cursor loader takes the uri and
calls the content resolver on our behalf
inside of an async task ultimately the
cursor gets returned to the Android UI
and it will be used by a cursor adapter
to populate the ListView in sunshine
from our database cursor similar to the
way our array adapter populated the list
view from an array for our next task
we're going to replace the array adapter
we have currently in forecast fragment
with a cursor adapter will eventually
connect it to our database using a
cursor loader